yo bernie is such a [ __ ] maggot bro
ya are such oh yeah you are you so hiked
about this bro let me tell you why this
is what bernie is Bernie got let's just
call it what the [ __ ] it is and I voted
for Bernie twice ok ok this is somebody
who I wanted to be present cuz I I
thought I was misled by Bernie I thought
he was actually good I thought he was
brave he is a [ __ ] coward
ok let's call it what it is Bernie toys
I vote for him once and he didn't get
into the situation where I could vote
for him this no but I was gonna vote for
him this right but basically I put you
my [ __ ] I wanted it right you you let me
down dawg so the DNC regardless of what
you want to say about the DNC you cannot
deny that they colluded to not allow him
to win the primary when with it when
Hillary when he was running with Hillary
yeah yeah and then they did the exact
same thing now now if you're listening
to this right now and you're going well
how did they collude they didn't have to
clued that crazy but they basically had
Buddha judge and clove ocker stop was it
go right before Super Tuesday they had
him drop out of the election but they
had Warren stay in so that Warren would
peel votes away from Bernie but all the
moderate Dems would have no competition
with Biden and all the moderate 10
voters would go to buy it and given him
super juice it basically handed on a
platter so instead of dividing up those
moderate demo Tamang those three they
all go to Biden he gets a big Super
Tuesday
whereas Bernie has to beat out
what's-her-face warrant for saying it
Elizabeth Warren right now granted
everybody's personally responsible for
where they are bernie is not good enough
that is a fact if this is a meritocracy
he does not have the skills he should be
a liberal arts teacher at [ __ ] Wesley
and he should not be running for
president that's who he is and that's
that how good he is of a politician he
is not good enough to make it he cannot
cut it he's not good enough we like his
ideas and we think we like him for who
he is but he doesn't have the skill okay
right if this was a real merit
he would fail say what you want about
Trump Trump faced similar adversity from
the Republican Party they're not as
corrupt as a Democratic Party in the way
that they rigged elections but they're
still corrupt right still corruption but
he was too much of a force for them to
control and he ended up with sun-hee
overwhelming it's [ __ ] blue cream
he's overwhelmed it he's over on him he
really that bernie is not as good as
Trump so he couldn't do it right and
he's also not willing to stoop as low as
Trump as well mr. Trump will get down
there boy Oh comfy in the mud that's
what he's made of
he's a mud person right so Bernie gets
raped by the DMC right with the Hillary
Clinton then endorses Hillary okay
literally all his supporters me I don't
know if you guys were supporting a
mainline we went yeah all of us believed
in him believed in his message right he
hands us over to his rapist it's like
you're the [ __ ] what is it the in the
Catholic Church the flower boy or some
[ __ ] what are they called altar boy
you're the altar boy you get raped by
the priests you become old enough to
bring in more altar boys and then you
bring in altar boys so they can all see
a red blood priest
yeah happens four years ago we're like
there's no rear there's no possible way
he's gonna let that happen again he
cares too much about us he cares too
much about the cause he cares too much
about these people who have supported
him they've put their hard-earned money
out there right we're again he's not
taking that super PAC money right the
average donation to Bernie Sanders $20
mm-hmm so that's poor Americans given
their last [ __ ] $20 to this [ __ ]
[ __ ] coward right in hopes that he
would help them and shed light on their
causes and what does he do he gets
stripped of his [ __ ] again collusion by
the same organization and right after
they rape him again what does he do
serves up his flock to the rapist again
endorses Biden
what would should he have done though
yeah call them out he should have called
out the corruption when they cheated him
with Hillary when they what did they do
they shut down there was some weird
thing that happened during the Hillary
primary with
shut down his ability to email they
something happened where they shut down
his email list or something like that
the DNC shut down so that he couldn't
have access to his email lists so you
shouldn't couldn't reach out to
supporters yeah they did all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] during the Hillary campaign
obviously the super-delegates [ __ ] he
should have called out the system he
should have called he's not a Democrat
yeah but he needs the proof he has a
proof it's out there we all know the
proof no that's all speculation you say
improve that they told all these
politicians oh drop out exactly at this
time so you don't split the votes and
they all know allegation by the second
Super Tuesday were Biden like sealed the
deal I think Warren was out at that
point that's the only thing that I think
they colluded this time it wasn't as
obvious I think early on the bootie
judge they were really trying to push
this guy and like he created the app
that everybody votes on is some dumb
[ __ ] like that and he wins two states
that's wild but I think by the end it
was just clear Biden was gonna win
Warren dropped out and Biden it was
gonna win because they made it that if
what if Bernie if Warren had dropped out
I think we can look up the numbers but
if Warren had dropped out then he could
have beaten Biden on Super Tuesday but
this [ __ ] who's just a part of the
[ __ ] establishment and again I'm not
angry at the idea of the establishment
I'm angry at hypocrites and Liars don't
act like you're fighting the system and
then feed us to the system you're
admitting me you're just a [ __ ]
distraction yeah but now that he has no
clear let me ask you a question more his
politics lined up with the Democratic
establishment not really is he even a
Democrat he doesn't claim to be he just
has to why didn't he run twenty twenty
run isn't independence on because he
said I think he has a better chance
getting Trump voters than he does Biden
supporters
that's like him running as a [ __ ]
communist like people just are gonna
vote for what they've run is it common
with Rahm run as a communist vote huh
he's not gonna get any votes people
don't feel comfortable they both they're
that hard but be better but here's the
thing he's not part of the party line
he's a pro gun guy can you name
Democrats that are pro-gun no he doesn't
align politically Democrats yes he
constantly both program he's in [ __ ]
what is he where's Iran Vermont
it's a pro-gun state and he had four
guns per capita than any other state in
the nation and to the point of running
an independent if you really want it
because my thing was well he just
doesn't want to see Trump win I think if
he ran independently he could take off
enough Trump voters that Trump might
lose because I think they're really the
people who are like big Trump supporters
are just like you know nobody [ __ ]
cares about us this guy does Bernie will
be like y'all I care about you here's
something that will actually make you
money I actually hate the rich he is
there it won't have a chance of winning
yes it can take some fo the reason for
him supporting for the reason for him
supporting Biden now is I just wanna see
Trump win that's the only thing I can do
but if you're an independent you could
keep Trump from winning there you go
why do black people in America have no
political power I go you sayin okay
why do they have no political power
don't vote no you do vote you vote the
same way every single time so you let
that party you basically you give the
party permission to do nothing for you
oh yes when one of you guys says I'm not
gonna vote for this party that does
nothing for you you call him a sellout
you call him a [ __ ] loser you call him
an Uncle Tom you call him piece of [ __ ]
so you're bullying each other into
maintaining the status quo that does
nothing for you right okay bye-bye bye
what's it called by Bernie handing us
all over to the Democratic Party he
continues that if you want your ideas
out there if you want your ideas to make
change you have to maintain an option so
then are you're upset that he didn't
that he ran as a Democrat or that he
dropped out like what are you upset
about both no but most importantly that
he dropped out and most of actually not
even dropping in doors Biden not even
dropped out don't endorse Biden [ __ ]
door some buy and call out the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you are 90 years old you're dead in a
few years you have nothing to lose here
go out on your sword go out on your
[ __ ]
so I feel the same way you know what
bernie is he's Yoel Romero in the fight
with uh style bender this your last
chance skull swing for the [ __ ]
fences bro
I think the way he's looking at it is
that if he goes out like that then his
mission is done he's out of your mission
is done yeah but now like now he's still
a senator right so he could still make
some chick what does he ever done what
changes the effort I'm just saying like
I think he just doesn't wanna you go
who's nuclear now it's go for nuclear
break it up power is not handed over is
[ __ ] taken okay and if you want to
make a change then you actually have to
put your foot down and make that [ __ ]
and he's too [ __ ] to put his foot down
and make it he's too [ __ ] to call it
the powers that be and he's handing us
right over to the same people that have
been [ __ ] over his party [ __ ] over
poor workers [ __ ] over everybody I
mean if you really look at his political
strategy it is more aligned with Trump
than the Democratic National Party 100%
foreign policy-wise foreign policy-wise
his pacifism in the rest of the world
and anti Wars
say good not health care say again
Health Care Alliance more with the Dems
economically he's I think aligned very
far left but you Nam he's very far left
health care he's very far left no yeah
yeah
economic and health care he's very far
left but foreign policy and he's pro-gun
like he's actually split I'm just saying
I hate the fact that he didn't have the
balls to call out the corruption that
was out there he just fell in line like
everybody else like a [ __ ] sheep
[Applause]